question on china uh china just
announced sanctions
yeah against six individuals and an
entity in the us in retaliation of
sanctions imposed by the by the
administration
uh on chinese officials over hong kong
do you think that this announcement
will complicate or impact any plans for
deputy secretary of state wendy
sherman's visit to chan jin
and is the administration concerned on
the escalating
sanctions potential escalating sanctions
war
well first i'm not aware of any changes
to her planned uh trip
and certainly we discuss not only areas
where we agree but areas where we
disagree
uh when we have engagements in
diplomatic meetings um
in terms of the sanctions we are aware
of course of the reports
that the prc has imposed sanctions on
several individuals and ngos including
at least one official from the previous
administration
were undeterred by these actions when we
remain fully committed
to implementing all relevant u.s
sanctions authorities
these actions are the latest examples of
how beijing punishes private citizens
companies and civil society
organizations as a way to send political
signals
and further illustrate the prc's
deteriorating deteriorating investment
climate and rising political risk
these actions would follow the baseless
sanctioning in march of two
commissioners from the u.s commission on
international religious freedom
the prc's january sanctions on 21 28
u.s officials and their july 2020
sanctions on u.s officials and
organizations promoting democracy and
human rights around the world
americans of both parties oppose these
outrageous moves to target those
who defend universal human rights and
fundamental freedoms and beijing's
attempt to intimidate and bully
internationally respected ngos
only demonstrate it's further isolation
from the world let's keep going i'm just
[Music]
so
okay
i installed some lights over top no
yep that works yeah that looks good yep
yeah
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
indian free spread
welcome to the wayne dupree show my name
is brady pre and you are looking at
liabella and brian smith
coaches we are live we are coming at you
and we and
and i know we're getting some extra eyes
right now because we're going to talk
about china
we're going to talk about china to start
off to and the reason why we're talking
about china and
we probably have some asian eyes is
because
you know i asked a question yesterday
the question is
or the question was is china
in i mean is china now the superpower
or do we still have our superpower
status
now one of the reasons why i asked that
question is because
if you look at how things are when you
owe somebody
you can't be on the same level you can't
you're not on the same level
uh and i mean you can say it until
you're blue in the face
unless you're hoarding the money and
keeping it for yourself
yeah we know people
all right
you know you can't be
uh the number one or keep saying that
you're number one
when you owe trillions and i don't know
how it got like that
but when you owe trillions to another
country you can't be number one
you can't right well when you're
investing in
infrastructure with the licensing nobody
ever seen china
and the people of china are starving for
energy
pure unadulterated energy that's what
they need all day all night and
coal fire plants are coming online
nuclear power plants coming online
everything they can possibly do the
three gorges dam that i was so
fascinated with about 15 to 20 years ago
they started building this dam is the
largest dam ever built in all of human
history
they started building it turned the
engines on on the trucks and for
15 years never turn them off that's how
long it takes to
build a dam now looking like that might
be a problem but still the whole point
is that they
were just so hungry for energy
in america when was the last time we
built anything
yeah for energy i mean really
yeah well here's the thing let's let's
look at it this way as well
china high-speed rail their food's
complex it's diverse it's cheap it's
delicious
almost all the younger generations uh
mobile payments instead of
cash okay on demand service apps where
you can actually get your errands done
for you
without even lifting a finger they'll
come to your house you just pay for it
on through your mobile app
and they'll mail out whatever you need
mailed out things like that and
also they have an e-commerce platform i
don't know if you know this that makes
amazon look like kmart
and i'm not talking kmart now i'm
talking the 1980s the alibaba
is much much bigger yeah than amazon
it's unbelievable
uh also they're implementing a new
reward system this this is actually
going to make
their people more healthier and happier
uh you get to a certain weight they give
you a reward
you get to you are a diabetic and you
get to a certain blood sugar level or
your blood pressure lowers
you get an extra 500 that month um if
you continue
underneath your uh i guess expected
weight for an entire year
they give you a thousand dollars things
like that they're going to start doing
with this reward system
so now they're making their people
happier as well and remember
now they know how to release a virus and
pretty much demolished
entire countries everybody's gdp
everybody's
uh uh net worth every single country
worldwide
shutdown and who was uh who was the
first country that was open
china and and they wrapped it in our
faces yes
they make you wonder before we before we
get to
uh before we get to the rest of it i
want to
welcome everybody once again to the show
we are being sponsored today by my
pillow
my pillow is uh an
awesome awesome i don't want to say tool
um the awesome company that
serves the patriots and americans
in a way that it will help
you do a better job in whatever you do
if you really accept the great products
that they have
and the reason why i said it is because
everybody needs to sleep
i know some people try to stay up as
long as they can i know some people have
insomnia
but the people i'm sure they lay down
and you know trying to fall asleep and
ladies and gentlemen
my pillar has great products and i want
you
um to visit mypillar.com and
you see that radio listener specials
little button right there
now you can use the code name wayne on
everything that you see there everything
but if you click on the radio special
radio listener specials you are going to
see
some of these prices that are cheaper
than what you see on the main side
right especially at the um six beats
tile set
yeah it's 39.99 with the code word wayne
but to bring the audience in so that way
you know you can kind of gain an
emotional attachment to this i want to
ask yourself how long do you spend in
bed
the major a normal person spends what
two thirds of their life sleeping
so it's very important to get an
a good rest and i didn't realize that
until i started using these products
and thought to myself wow here i thought
i had anxiety or maybe i was like a long
covet hauler because i had covet in the
past
and then i got a mattress topper and
actually high quality sheets
and i'm like wait i don't have anxiety
as bad as i thought i did and i'm not a
long covet hauler you guys know what the
problem was
i wasn't sleeping enough i wasn't
sitting down my darn phone
i was holding on to that till midnight
dealing with people answering emails no
i put the phone down at nine o'clock and
i laid just like her
and held my pillow and i was out by ten
and now i'm getting
you know 10 to 12 hours of sleep that's
what i need and it's thanks to my pillow
so get at least a my pillow and the
sheets
and maybe if you can afford it the
mattress topper we do have special deals
on that
but you guys spend a lot of time
sleeping and in your bed so
look at that 49.99 that's unbelievable
it's 89.99 49.99
49.99 with the promo code and
brian brian actually has uh
yeah if you guys ever thought about or i
know everybody does
and since i've been married for the last
15 years
it's been more important to me to make
sure i get a good mattress
before i could have cared less because
it was unimportant but now
it's really super important to me and to
my family and i'm telling you right now
this
adjustable platform as usb ports
underneath on both sides
has that little it looks like a little
antenna or a wand sticking up
it it's actually voice controlled to
where you can talk to it and tell it
what to do to move up to move down
i got a zero g gravity where it's
programmed in
your legs are just slightly higher than
your head and it feels like you're
floating
uh if you got any kind of pains in the
hips knees back or whatever
it just eases all of that as you just
float there
with the zero g programming you program
your own settings
it's got a little night light that's
just like a just like a
haze glow really really really dim glow
night light on its own or you can hit a
button
and the whole bottom illuminates for a
really nice
light but it's not in your eyes it's
just it's on the floor so you can walk
around at night
um i i can't say it about this thing
oh and it's also got a massage feature
for the head and for the feet
um it's just you gotta get it man
you gotta get it you wanna sleep right
that's how you sleep right right there
yeah ladies and gentlemen we are telling
you
we use our products we want you to use
their products
mypillow.com forward slash radio
specials
or you can use codename wayne on
all of the products you're going to get
something off
all right with that said uh
we'll actually we'll come back to that
in a little bit but
i wanted to get on to the the china
situation the china situation
uh something happened
over the weekend a china diplom a a chin
a senior ambassador a senior diplomat
told american deputy secretary
wendy sherman that the by minute that
the biden administration's
strategy of pursuing both confrontation
and cooperation with
beijing was sure to fail
china's vice foreign minister ji fang
told
sherman that the united states
competitive
collaborative and adversarial
you know adversarial rhetoric was a
thinly veiled attempt to contain and
suppress
china uh sherman's meetings offered the
latest
gauge of the by administration strategy
of stepping up pressure against the
chinese government
on several fronts if you've been
watching this show again the reason why
biden or the reason why we the reason
why i feel that biden
is publicly sounding like he's getting
tough
is because he has to maintain some sort
of
act act as an act okay it's an act
but we all know that he
answers to china he can't even speak on
things that china is
doing to america as a matter of fact
i'm going to play this and then i'm
going to get my co-host mr president
she jumps up before you do effectively
your administration is naming and
shaming china but no sanctions
why and is that effective enough they're
still determining exactly what happened
the investigation is not finished
[Music]
what is your understanding of the
biggest difference between what they've
done
versus what russia has done in terms of
cyber action
that take a longer explanation we have
all the time in the world
no we don't i have to go see the king of
jordan
to the best of my knowledge and i'm
getting a report tomorrow morning on
this
detailed report my understanding is
that the chinese government
not unlike the russian government is not
doing this themselves
but are protecting those who are doing
it and maybe even accommodating them
being able to do it
that may be the difference but you know
what
we look we knew that back in 2016. when
when the media just said russia's
packing russia
yeah but but y'all leaving china out
china
china look i said
hackers are born in in china they aren't
made they are
born they they come out of the womb the
next thing
they got their laptop they got a they
got espresso
they're hitting the thing you want your
lollipop no can i have a bitcoin bitcoin
they say that's their first word
yeah can i have a uh can i have a usb
double shot soy latte
i can have a usb stick over here i need
to save
this stuff down and you know they go to
school
all year long so you know
i don't know well i mean they've
infiltrated hollywood years ago they
spied on our colleges they control our
pharmaceutical drugs our technology
is not half as advanced as theirs and
their cyber warfare
abilities are rigorous and
their military is young and strong and
getting bigger by the day
and i can't i'm sorry you guys but i
can't blame china
100 on this i have to blame us too i
have to blame our leaders for allowing
this to go on as long as it has
they have given they have sold out
they have turned a blind eye continually
still doing that and they've accepted
china's reign so really when you want to
point fingers yeah i get it that all
roads lead to china
but why is that it's because american
politicians
and american officials have led it going
on so long i blame them
are you speaking about the military and
and the videos that have gone viral
about the american military the new
campaign videos
uh lgbt friendly uh female friendly
issue i mean it's just really really sad
sorry uninviting uh
uh the mask it's a there's it's just
there's no men wanted type of
ads where you've got china you've got
russia you've got all these other
countries that are putting ads out
trying to attract their own population
and they're just
uh you know badass dude so just like
dudes in the military we got the the
best equipment
the best bombs the best size the best
technology this this
everything else and and when you look at
america's
it's just it's so sad it's so weak
and it's so they they're they've become
appeasers
to the big bullies on the block that are
trying to try to get us
all to appease to these bullies on the
block and the rest of the world is
watching and they're just shaking their
head
at how far this great experiment has
fallen
watch this i talked to she xi jinping in
china
who i know well we don't agree on a lot
of things he's a bright
and really tough guy
i don't know look i don't know if
i don't know
if he should have said anything bad
about
xingping i i don't know all i'm i'm
saying is
maybe if you were a little bit more real
talkish
uh you know yeah i know
the chinese president and uh
yes he is adverse yes he is adversarial
uh you know we don't get along on many
things but
there are a couple of things that we do
get along so but we are going to keep
door open for talks so that we can work
together
uh with our two countries but
uh the time is over for allowing them to
walk all over the united states america
i mean that's basically what donald
trump said
but why couldn't i mean but why praise
the guy
if the guy if the country is cleaning
your clock
the country is clean china is cleaning
america's clock
they they um they
is this you know what i ain't even gonna
do the accent okay i'm just gonna talk
regularly
because i don't want nobody to get that
feeling
yeah is this the nba yeah we got
one billion dollars for you if you come
over and do
a couple of camps okay fine thank you is
this the hockey league
yeah we got a billion dollars for you if
you can come over and teach
uh the kids money talks man
and it it's strange when they're
shelling out all this hey knight we want
to run an ad
yeah uh yeah a billion dollars
they are buying oh hollywood yeah
um we want to put out
15 movies this year we're going to give
you
20 billion dollars yeah okay all right
goodbye they're shouting out money
toward us
or the people in higher places
and we're like
give me some i need i need i'm really
coughing here but
[Music]
i need i need it but then there but then
they're charging
us so much they're taking our
intellectual property they're stealing
and then they're giving not only are
they giving those big thing
big corporation stuff money they're also
feeding
our middle class our poor fentanyl
bad bad prescription drugs and stuff and
also uh
covet and monkey pox right and
we're over here the military is arguing
if men should be offended
and calling them he she him or her
and and their military is looking and
saying hey we're all going to kill your
he she's men and women that's what we
want to do we want to take you down
you know and and that's the problem with
it joe is so woke that
what's his name xi jinping yeah not his
name
well okay well his name over here would
be them jing ping because she would be
offensive right he would have to change
his name from
to he jinping i mean that's how bad it
is over here in america that that's what
we're doing well
nancy pelosi she's trying to say that
everybody in congress should be
using pronouns and stuff well it's at
some point
you know how everybody sees well those
that see
aliens all say that they're just like
clear colored
and they have no body parts just long
fingers and big eyes
that's literally what congress wants us
to become no body parts
no specific color just long fingers and
big eyes so that way we can work harder
and pay more taxes literally
that's what we're that's what they're
heading for that's what they all want us
to look like
uh and it's sad but here we are we're
fighting amongst each other
we're not keeping our eye on the ball
and china's laughing the whole way to
the bank
and they're laughing the whole way as
they take over africa as they take over
other areas of the countries and we're
going to be left with just this little
bitty
united states and they're going to own
everything else this did you ever play
the game risk
yeah well that's where we're at right
now this would be marx's
absolute dream his absolute dream
of a communist organization uh being set
up
in china with the billions and billions
of workers uh the slave workers to
actually help support the thing
while china then goes to all these other
countries
to infiltrate the countries to sell
their cheap stuff
to garner their stuff back to move back
so china's using communism in a way that
is completely manipulative they
manipulate their own markets they
manipulate their own currency
for their own benefit and their
government controls it all
what we saw during the cold war the only
way we won the cold war
is because pure unadulterated capitalism
outspent
the ussr and the ussr was run by a bunch
of
nut jobs now we've got i mean not jobs
over china too but now we've got china
who's literally become the hegemony
everything runs through china when it
comes to trade
and they're making money off all that
stuff while we're sitting over here
electing to joe biden to 81 million
folks
you're right also also go
go towards oh well we're going to
sanction you for human rights and stuff
and china's like
okay do whatever you want go to hell
do you know what happened when covet
started
over there in china now got the who to
cover for them
yeah they shut down everything so that
everybody
uh was not on the streets and stuff like
that
and they didn't tell us right they
didn't tell us but they kicked
a lot of africans out of their homes
out of their homes y'all and we didn't
say anything
africans now china went i
china but both of them have toji china
has
gone down to africa and set up shop
they set up shop in the entire country
of italy they literally own
italy now but they kick africans out of
their homes
during the covet and made them homeless
man that's messed up
i mean i'm wrong yeah look
but then but but but i but our side
they survived human rights violations
tell somebody let them do what they're
going to do
yeah and they scream you i mean look at
hollywood and the rest of them cnn
they're screaming climate change
and and who's the biggest offender to
climate change there is
number one number one
combined china is more than
every nation combined
right they won't say anything and i
think it's so odd because if you just
stop
china and their pollution we literally
wouldn't even have to stop any of ours
it would change the whole world but yet
no one wants to say anything to china
and china
do you think china cares they don't care
the re-education camps for the muslims
they don't care
their climate change issue their climate
that is literally
ruining everything they don't care the
way that they treat viruses and let them
escape
they don't care at what point and that's
what i always try to say here on the
show
at what point do we realize that it's
not about he
she them or it or wear a mask or don't
wear a mask of the vaccine
none of that's gonna matter when they
kill you
okay it's all over so it doesn't matter
if you're man or female or if you're
wearing a mask if you've got a vaccine
if we're literally
getting killed by china because honestly
they want our land
i'm not gonna lie to you they want our
land yeah they gotta feed their people
and just a flashback that anybody
remember the beijing olympics
months and months leading up to the
olympics uh all traffic was banned
through beijing
uh the government came in put a lockdown
on everything
created these giant fans to blow all the
smog
and clean up the city that's all they
did for months and months and months to
clean the city
so that when the beijing olympics showed
up you'd be like look see it's beautiful
here
there's no problems no problems here
it's beautiful
yeah and just remember that they're very
patient they're very
patient
so even if they know that they can't get
to our land for another 20
30 40 years it's not going to matter but
you know what scares me
it's the younger generation like scott
uh says in the chat
that are complacent they're completely
fine with china taking over
as long as they get a check and they
feel accepted
they will pretty much do whatever it is
and that's what's scary as long
as th this new generation has their
phone their big phone their
their earbuds their awesome playlists
and they're uh and uh
they're living with their parents in the
basement they don't care about nothing
they don't fight they fight for
tick-tock trump tried to get it shut
down and they got angry man
they fought for tick tock they were
fighting for china
and even though trump said look this is
china back you don't understand the
propaganda we don't care we love it
they're literally claiming their
allegiance to china this younger
generation
and they don't care yeah because why
they have better technology and it's
cool
and it is also kumbaya you know oh well
we do
we need to love each other you know we
we we
we need to just uh combine hands and
stuff
okay well while while we're getting
right we're reaching out in hands to
combine each other
they're putting their hands in our
pockets taking
whatever you've got and then going back
home yeah we got them
how do you make that we'll make it this
way and cheaper yeah yeah yeah and then
we'll celebrate back to them
you know i mean and oh oh and that's not
the only template they use
these the same template of going to our
colleges
getting all these scholarships and these
grants and stuff
learning everything and then
going back home with it all right yep
well don't you think it's
funny that a lot of these uh chinese
college students come over here with a
half a million dollars in their bank
account i know the government's giving
it to them
exactly at the university of purdue
if you are a foreign student you've got
to prove
that you can pay in full for the full
four year ride
plus pay for a room and board for the
entire four years
and that campus engineering huge
engineering campus
can overrun oh yeah they don't even
blame
by asians and all you got to do is come
up with probably
you know maybe about 200 200 000 for the
schooling for four years maybe three
hundred thousand
then about another couple hundred so
maybe a cool meal cool mill will float
you for
for four to six years at the university
you know whatever
and chad brings up a good point yes like
how 911 we taught the terrorist pilots
how to fly
that's exactly what's happening we
didn't question that didn't request
that and now we're literally teaching
chinese spies how to overtake america
from the inside
right right they probably
walked the chinese spot it was in dianne
feinstein's office for 20 years they
probably
walked that person in to oh
the uh the the printer's over there the
he's a friend of a friend he needs
a job yeah the secret browser and that
office right there the key is there
whenever you need it you know the
chinese spot was in her office for 20
years
yeah i know i know a guy named schwab
well he he needs a date do you know
anybody that uh
hunter biden's good at blowing paint so
maybe him and
they can get together and blow some
paint
you know
it still blows my mind this kid comes up
with some of this crazy stuff that he
says it's insane
this is the president's son yeah
20 years 20 years
and she didn't get in trouble no imagine
where all the bugs were
all the wire tabs all the audio tabs all
everything cell phone taps whatever you
want you could have taken
you could have taken 10 years to tap
everything
and then you got 10 years to listen to
it all what
and and then and then the spy with
swalwell
and he didn't and he's still on the
board nancy was like i'll just stay on
dude you're cool
you're cool security yes he didn't get
kicked off of any of his panels
none no no yeah i mean
look hello okay uh well what's your
solution
well it's a long shot
it's a long i got a solution i don't
know if i want to stand
right now she's talking about a final
solution we're not talking about yeah
yeah no no no no i truly think hollywood
i'll tell you my solution i think
hollywood needs to shut down friday
yeah no i think hollywood needs shut
down completely i think all movies need
to be stopped and i think every single
person that's powerful in hollywood
needs investigated for chinese ties
like spies the jackie chan thing alarmed
me entirely too much
and now i look at hollywood more as a
ccp controlled spy unit
than i do hollywood and that includes
tom cruise in this propaganda
massive amounts of propaganda my
children loved jackie chan until i told
him what was up
yeah jackie chan that doesn't fit well
with me whatsoever
and that's the first thing that i need
that needs done i think the second thing
that needs done is i think that we have
to
uh investigate every single person in
congress and the senate i think there
are
more ccp connections in there than what
you think there are
you prepared for them to call you the
next uh
mccarthy because you know what mccarthy
had it right
so i'm there i'm concerned about those
two things next i want to talk about the
colleges
i am worried about these uh
tuition well actually no let me rephrase
that the teachers the professors and the
colleges
i actually did a study and saw how much
each one of them were making
it's more it's it's so much money wayne
and brian
that i can't even believe the colleges
can afford them so it tells me
that the colleges aren't directly paying
them and if they are
uh that's great but they're getting
their money elsewhere so it makes me
wonder how many ccp spies
or influencers are actually professors
in our colleges as well
they can write their own books have them
printed and made in china
come back and make it mandatory when you
take these classes it is
mandatory to buy the book the professor
for 100 120 dollars by every student by
a hundred kids
you talk about some money and none of
the college deans are sitting in on
these college classes and listening
what's going on
aka indoctrination that's why we're
seeing our young group of people
pledging allegiance basically to ccp and
last but not least our scientists
i'm really worried for our doctors and
our scientists the way that they've
handled covid
with the mass scientists anymore
i'll be honest with you i trust john
hopkins biology i do not
i do not think that they're political
and i trust the cleveland clinic that's
the only two places i will go for
information
and you kind of have to watch who you're
listening to in there as well but our
doctors and scientists are bought and
paid for by the ccp i'm not saying all
of them you say
cleveland clinic i i in there by all or
how do you say it there's that in
cleveland yeah
i don't trust nothing out of cleveland
well they're good they're good
but um besides that i think that we
should look at our scientists and our
doctors as well
i knew a girl one time from cleveland
that wasn't good
that's all another eric solo case huh
yeah
pretty much
well you've got to sign up for uh censor
tv to check that show out guys
no i didn't say it on there did i did i
say it on there i don't
i don't think i'd ever say out loud my
solution did she say it
i don't think mine insinuated to it
who knows yeah yeah we don't censor it
again this friday
you check that one out it might come out
this friday maybe i'll give my solution
on friday
uncensored just real quick
my personal solution we need to get back
to the basics
of what made this country great we need
to get back to a moral
uh guard railed a country we've lost all
morals
lost everything to do uh whatever feels
right
at any given time in any given whim and
exactly
you literally hang your own society
that's what i'll be doing on friday when
i say my answer
well unfortunately brian i don't think
we can get there because we are so
ingrained now with technology that you
can't differentiate who's american and
who's china
who's a chinese spy anymore you know it
was different in the 50s when you
couldn't just
hop on a plane and go over to china for
20 minutes and come back and spread a
virus
it's sad i don't like where we're going
only nixon can go to china
and trump and trump went to china
trouble bad ass style like he said it
took me a bigger it took me a second to
figure out what you're
doing
[Laughter]
i remember i remember watching i
remember watching archie monkey yeah i
watch archie monkey
i remember i remember once it was fun
when
she did when he just were talking he was
like
[Music]
and that's what he was doing the whole
entire time
[Laughter]
okay um
california california to require proof
of covet 19 vaccination
unvaccinated staff state employee state
employees ladies and gentlemen
will be required to get tested at least
once a week if they
do not have well actually
let's see california will require all
state employees and health
care workers to provide proof of
vaccinations or get regularly tested
i mean the surge of cases from the
highly contagious delta
uh variant governor gavin newsom
announced in a press conference on money
all
employees will be required these are
called kobe
and covet passports by the way they just
don't have a name for it yet
mr clover passports our employees will
be required to approve
they have received a vaccine by showing
their vaccination cards
or through a verification code provided
by the california department of health
if you are going to an event
cam um concert park
restaurant
uh i'm not gonna say church events but
if you're some type of event baseball
football hockey yeah
exactly tennis you're gonna have to
prove
soccer that you got the covet vaccine
before you get in it
right however our government has also
said that there has to be
uh left a small margin a small
room for those that cannot physically
take the vaccine and
religious and i'm gonna tell you right
now i am now classifying myself
as an extreme religious individual to
the point to where
somebody somebody else told me this so
i'm using somebody else i don't know who
it was
they said for me to wear a mask or to
take a vaccine
would be altering the image of god
well yeah because we're made in the end
of god
and so my belief can't alter the image
of god it can't hide the image of god
in my belief so uh that's that's my
religion
well i hope you can all see how
prejudiced
rem is losing my religion i hope every i
hope everybody sees how prejudiced
the democrat party is and what does
prejudice mean it means it's an
unreasonable dislike of someone or
something
or an unreasonable preference for one
group over another because
why aren't they requiring proof of
previous covet infection
yes becky i'm with you right right
proof of previous covet infection is
just as good as vaccine that is
prejudiced
that those people are loot are losing
out
they're starting to slowly put slide
into mainstream media
up previous covet infections now they
don't want to come out right and say it
just yet but they're starting to hint
around
that it's just as good or better as the
vaccine um and that they will be able to
accept proof of previous covet
infections
as there was a study i did find a study
that was done
that did show that previously infected
was excellent was great yeah it's almost
700 times the vaccine amount and
probably last longer too
probably years and it was hard to find
that article like it really didn't dig
for it
wait what i didn't hear what okay so the
previous previous there was an article
written that showed
uh previously infected individuals
versus vaccinated individuals
and the previously infected that that
you know
got better by you know i think it's like
99 survival rate
uh it deferred much better than
vaccinated individuals correct
and it lasts longer they think that the
tnb cells are still being created and
those that have had coven
meaning that the uh immunity found after
coveted recovery
could probably last even years this
comes from the
and the national institute of health the
nih.gov
the immune system of more than 95 people
who recovered from coven 19 had durable
memories of the virus
that lasts over eight months resulting
in
long-lasting immunity could be even
bigger than the vaccine
so this this is what i want to just let
everybody know as we know the pcr tests
have been shut down as of december 31st
2021.
they were faked because they were over
they were oversensitive okay so we can
we can use the example i saw this online
we can use the example of pugs
let me just show let me just give you
this example when they were using the
pcr testing
it was turned up so high that it was
only supposed to search for say
pugs we're gonna use dogs for example
well not only did it search for pugs it
searched for cats
and it searched for anything that was
breathing with four legs okay
that's how this uh pcr testing tested so
a lot of people that got their noses
swabbed and tested positive for covid
you may have just had the flu so my
question is if you've
had if you had the pcr testing done and
you tested positive for coven and they
never gave you a flu test
but you did not lose your taste and
smell i'm wondering if maybe you just
had the flu
well there was an article just written
they're saying that they're going to
mandate that when you do go in for
covatest that they're going to mandate
that you test for the flu as well right
and why weren't they doing that i mean
my husband
or anything but i'll tell you why oh i
know why but i'm saying they swabbed his
nose for covert and then he came home
and i said well they test you for the
flu too
no just covet three days later they
called back if they would have called
back and said hey you were negative for
covet it's probably the flu
and he just chalked it up as the flu it
would never have been recorded as the
flu
the problem was they were over testing
for covid they were under testing for
the flu a lot of these cases were
probably the flu
if you didn't lose your taste and smell
don't be too positive you had coveted
you need to go get the antibody testing
to see if you did have covet get the igg
antibody test
to see if you had coveted because i got
a funny feeling you probably just had
the flu or the cold and i think all
drivers
was cranked all three of us i think are
in agreement
that when government officials whether
it be fouchy whether it be bloomberg
whether it be
whoever across the board when they are
tempting people with unhealthy foods i
mean it's just insanity
tempting people with cheeseburgers and
french fries and malted milkshakes and
ice cream
if you get the vaccine we're going to
give you this stuff and oh and by the
way if
you're in las vegas go to the hustler
casino
get your vaccine and get your free lap
dance
that's true that is not a joke that's a
god's honest truth
no way we are not doing this man come on
[Music]
come on man we gotta keep this straight
and just to let you know sugar lower
what do you say in light dance
[Laughter]
and just let you know 75 milligrams of
sugar lowers the immune system and
actually affects the white blood cells
for about five straight hours so after
you get your coven vaccine and you're
walking out all proud eating your
doughnut
then your immune system lowers itself
for five hours
making you more susceptible to coving it
that way
yeah no for real
you're not getting the vaccine anyway so
you would never be in that situation
now you gotta get the juice yeah now you
gotta get it
yeah you gotta get the jab with the
juice
segregation 2021 yes that's what it is
ladies and gentlemen it's
it is segregation 2021.
we saw it we knew it was going to happen
as
even said it on the show they're going
to make
those who do not want the vaccine the
enemy
they are i mean and they like lepers
basically whether you've had it or not
it doesn't matter
right you won't be able to get in to do
anything they're going to cite you when
you go in
so it's almost like a poor man's 666
uh i don't really care though i'm not
i'm not i don't i then i don't go to
restaurants then guess what my local
restaurants
you're all going to shut down because
i'm in a conservative area yeah but yeah
but look
everybody ain't got no guns on a
mountain to shoot
wildlife either i'm just saying if it
gets to that point in america that i
can't go anywhere
i don't want to go anywhere anyways
that's where that's where i would be
sorry no i'm not do what i do at home i
understand
but um you know they're gonna require it
for for
uh grocery stores yeah for whatever i
mean
they really believe that you and they
desperately want this because they saw
how much control they were able to
garner
without having it can you imagine what
they're talking about
in the background oh man they come
they're sick with it
they are coming for
i mean they already are pushing out the
reason why things are so bad is because
people aren't getting back
we've got to get back to no it's because
people are living on top of each other
in india their health care sucks
and then they got the mutated virus and
they had to change it over to a greek
name because they don't want to blame
india because that's that is a genius
idea what they did there
so that way that we can't blame these
these uh third world countries for
causing it but when you've got people
with aids that it's living in their
system for months and months at a time
and it mutates it's not america that's
even getting the mutations
it's third world countries take care of
them i tell you somewhere else they're
living on top of each other
in china yeah where the virus came they
they have real
small apartments for the the middle the
low class or whatnot
i mean some of their apartments are like
uh
i mean i was watching a documentary one
time
you know how you imagine you just laying
down
on a uh
not even queen a twin bed a train jail
cell it's like as small as a jealousy
twin bed right it's stacked on top of
each other it goes up about three levels
your walls are closed in on
that twin bed so if you have uh
um counters or levels you know stuff to
put your stuff on
it's all the way around there but that's
your house that's your
house that's you see right on the
internet you should pull it up and check
it sounds like
yes jeb said they all need my pillow
mattress toppers that's hilarious
um yeah that's great uh yeah but
um why didn't they get covered as bad as
what they should have
yes jebs has a good sense of humor and
he's he's always one to put something
out
well if they had the my pillow matches
tops maybe they sleep better
come on man but you know their covert
rate should have been through the roof
but now we're seeing
that uh i don't know if you guys have
saw the report on who
who's getting the worst covet and how
bad it is but you should google it
because um
asians are not affected half as bad
as what europeans are it's very
interesting to see
let's see i wonder i wonder if
[Music]
now you know and i probably can't do
this because i don't want to
get um yeah you don't want anything with
music or sound yeah um okay good
good i can do this um
uh the documentary that i was watching
uh
was on youtube and uh
basically they were showing how
this guy yeah that's just his that's his
place
that's his place and yeah that's his
house
ryan is so offended he had to leave
really
oh yeah he just couldn't handle it um
but yeah oh look at that talk about fire
hazards see
this i mean this could be coming to an
america near you and the younger
generation just doesn't get it
right exactly yeah wow
and on top of
him there live someone on top of him
and beside him you know it's it's
it's a stack it's a stack um and pack
him type of
i mean now the guy that was narrating
the
entire thing he was in a wheelchair but
he
couldn't even really get into that area
you know uh yeah i mean but it's people
all along that little hallway and stuff
and that's nothing
yeah yeah it's it's where'd they go the
bathroom way in that white little
ice cream container there or they
also have a small community bathroom
down the hall
but a community bathroom a community
bathroom yet and i do that's why i don't
understand how covet did not ravage
china other than it was not meant for
them
there's no other answer you guys yeah
um and i don't know i don't know if
y'all know this
but in california
they are also
building things like this where the
younger generation
is paying close to four or five thousand
dollars a month
for something like this yeah they want
to live in pods
they actually think that it's yeah they
think it's great to live in a pod
um this this right here is a pod
in chinese generation l for lost
my goodness yeah who would who did it
right there i know you've got to see
that right
yeah right you got you got this tiny
home fad i understand that
you got this tiny living fan i
understand that it's kind of cool
but but this this pod living
this is insane then they said like what
they want to do is create a pod that
puts you into homeostasis so you see how
he lays there what will happen is
there'll be a scan that comes through
him and actually scans his body to see
what he needs
what he doesn't need he'll be able to
put himself administer ivs if he needs a
vitamin d
that day or if he's a little dehydrated
uh
he'll be able to do things like that uh
you know turn off the
lights if he needs more uh darkness
things like that right
yeah clap on clap off they say these
pods
cause less death because you're not
cleaning out your
uh gutters and it with leaves or you're
not mowing your grass things like that
they're saying they're more efficient
therefore leading to a happier lifestyle
audience do you feel like this is a
happier lifestyle because i don't feel
like it would be
you know candace in the chat room says
so sad people said no this is not a
happier lifestyle
but that's what they're claiming it
would be they want to sell you on the
fact
we own you you don't have any bills you
live in a pod
so you'll be happier okay lack of
exercise lack of sunlight
lack of walking around lack of just the
freedom to just
be to walk outside i can walk out my
back door into the grass in the backyard
we've got all kinds of gardens and
trees whatever just enjoying i got four
wheelers and atvs and little gold cars i
got my truck i can work on my truck
i mean just nice neat cool stuff that i
can hang out with the kids
this you're you're isolated by yourself
and don't tell me you're going to talk
to the pod mate next to you
that ain't happening this is not going
to happen you go back to your point of
uh riding quads and going in your
backyard
the reason why bill gates you realize
that we should probably be taking a
stand
against ccp purchased american land
because they are purchasing our land
at high rates uh in texas especially we
also have bill gates buying up farmland
farmland in the midwest um we don't
really know why his people won't give us
answers but could it be one reason to
create pods like this so we don't have
you know fresh air to run and drive our
quads on i don't know but the more land
they own the less we have movement
what's the next step the matrix now some
of you yeah
you're right plug people in some of you
some of you have mortgages that are that
might be
1200 or less okay 12 or 1200
or less you have a whole lot of square
footage and everything
but in san francisco these pods that you
saw in china
these pods are growing for young kids
some of these kids are paying 1200 a
month and
they're happy to do it they i mean it's
it's
you know they brainwash they share
they're very happy to do it
oh they oh my god because you have to be
raised in a culture to enjoy this
there's no way this isn't natural this
isn't
no it's not it's not it's not natural
twelve hundred dollars
for a bed space that's it no
now granted i don't live near anywhere
near san francisco
live on the west side of cincinnati
where the medium income is probably
about
50 60 000 a year you live really nice at
65 000 a year
it's it's awesome it's great uh my
mortgage is
750 755 a three stories
six bedrooms two bathrooms it was an old
hundred year old house
it was a two family i converted it into
a single family
plenty of room plenty of space
nice the kids go on one floor i go on
another floor
i told you didn't i i told you
a phone a playlist earpods that's it
right
that's exactly what it is and keep in
mind that a community
a social unit of group living one of
those communes right
um they share a sense of placed situated
uh like this kind of where they're just
on their
phones they're just on their computers
but they all can live together because
they have
one thing in common and that's they want
to be in this commune they want to be
able to just
live off the computer cheaply because
they don't care about you
or what what you're doing your
neighbor's doing uh
so yeah this is gonna be the new thing
where it's like five or six of them in a
campfire
kind of camp i don't think they're
healthy at all here's proof of that
yeah here's proof of it not being a
healthy thing back in germany in world
war
ii the germans experimented with babies
a set of babies that were not touched
just fed and a set of babies that were
fed and touched and loved on
and they quickly saw that the babies
that weren't held that weren't coddled
that weren't taken care of loved on
they started to die very very quick fast
forward all the way till now
and cove in 2020 where people couldn't
hold each other couldn't hug each other
couldn't touch each other
and and i'm not talking about sexual
sense i'm talking about in a friendly
uh sense that that's it
so they did the study in this church
organization showed
that we absolutely need the human touch
and
human interaction with each other which
which helps
us in internally uh you know
being able to cope with society cope
with the world
uh being happier being more emotionally
fit
and when you go to churches that
churches that are happy healthy churches
i'm not among all
churches i'm specifically referring to
my church when i show up there
dudes are giving dudes hugs
i it was weird to me to begin with
because i was raised not to hug anybody
but
i'll tell you what there's something
something about that guys
sharing uh uh the lord with each
other and and absolutely allowing each
other to be
uh you know emotionally open
well the baby uh history lesson that you
were given there that was called nurture
versus nature
right and um it didn't go so well new
but not at all they love the pods the
younger generation has got to have
constant approval have you noticed that
they have to have constant reassurance
that they are beautiful
and they are loved and they are accepted
and how do you get that you get a whole
group of people that live with you and
then you become like this cult-like
family
oh i think i remember that david crush
didn't he do something like that
yeah wow i don't know branson
was a little different that's why i mean
waco texas i'm a little weird out there
yeah well i mean a whole lot of crazies
used to bob of
in their own in their own way i mean it
i remember a sun group i don't know how
they did it
i don't know what it but the report they
showed they walked into a place
everybody in there everybody in there
and it was locked from the inside
it was locked from the inside everybody
in there was
laid out on the bed but the blue
jumpsuits with gym shoes on
well it had a blanket over top of their
faces and stuff okay okay yeah yeah but
but that but that was a cult like tight
grip look
um it is not the kool-aid and died
right it is not healthy for
this pod thing or what china is doing to
america
or what or how they buy the
administration or all the politicians
i just thought and all the politicians
are allowing this to happen
leah said earlier no bro one of my host
mates said earlier that uh they've been
allowing this to happen for so long
you just can't blame it on china you
have to blame it on the politicians
because the politicians
have allowed it to happen they have
turned their head they've turned their
back
they they're enabling china that's what
they're doing they're the great enablers
they get in front of the cameras like
they're talking tough
but they're not when the cameras are
turning off that
can you forgive me for what i said yeah
uh meech for dinner
okay thanks they i mean they really
don't
there's nothing there that is stopping
china
from doing what they're doing i mean
what he said yesterday they're putting
the sun up in the thing we already knew
that they were putting a moon
right in the solar system or up above
the earth now
now they're putting a sun yeah they're
creating a sun in conjunction with
i think it's like sweden or switzerland
another country the
european union and they literally want
to create
more energy by creating another sun
yeah and we're worried about it how do
you sleep
i'm gonna tell you what you're gonna get
sleep deprivation go to tow
up there to alaska or go up there north
in canada where it's sunny for six
months
straight you're gonna go crazy you they
they do
they go nuts real quick i um
this is this is kind of it's kind of big
uh i read something about long covet i
don't know that much about it
but it says that the effects are wide
ranging from joint pain
to fevers to fatigue the hair losses
sound like
people getting older but whatever um
long covet could qualify
as a disability they want to hand out
more money
we found out during obama's era that
once you get on disability
you don't give
that's
freaking crazy
disability now
you know what honestly honestly i think
i've been watching
i've look i've been watching people
survive on the island and all that stuff
lately
i think it's time for me to move to an
island i'm serious i think it's time for
me
to take myself onto an island
it was going on here's the thing
everybody
can claim that they've had long-term
covet if they've ever had covet what are
you guys doing i think y'all got some
brain damage from the coven
um but anyways what'd she say listen
no this is really important i want you
to hear this part this is how they get
us
to income based
country to get us to one income this is
how they do it
because if everybody goes out and claims
long-term covet and gets payments
this is how they get to that i'm telling
you
it's coming in
i agree gina
what you doing over there blind i can't
see you around
okay there you go brian needs to figure
out his electronics
hey blindly what you doing oh me
brian's phone gets too warmed up and
then it's hot in here get a fan
do something
[Laughter]
get one of those obama phones maybe
that'll those will work better
we're full we're falling apart here
let's folks some cbd in here that's the
wheels coming off that end
yeah the wheels are coming off anytime
your wheels are coming off you can
always go to cbdline.com
and uh that'll help get your wheels back
on and again last night
i we we stayed up late we were at the
soccer thing
we got home about nine i wasn't ready
for bed but i knew i had to go to bed
because i had to get up early
took the slumber berry and in about 30
minutes i told everybody get out of my
room i'm
tired of turning out the lights within
30 minutes slumber berry
slept like a log for about six solid
hours
i woke up alarm clock didn't go off i
looked at it
it's four minutes late and i was like
that didn't go off but i'm up let's go
dvd line helping people sleep in for
work that's all right
let's get spending four minutes
i love the
gummies i'm out too by the way but i
love gummies i love
the lotion
uh the tinctures i put it in my
smoothies
and you know what i still i still got
something i just i still got some of
those slumber birds
i can't eat those slumber berries like
the regular ones because i might never
wake up
send them to me i love them i mean i eat
them i eat them but i only do one
one i need two well i have a friend who
is like kind of narcoleptic and she
wanted the slumber berries that i had
and i told her no
way she sleeps through her fire alarms
her house caught on fire
yeah well she's like borderline they
can't diagnose her with it but they said
she does have a sleeping disorder
and i was like no you're not taking me
she slept through a fire in her house in
the fire alarms and she thinks that i'm
going to give her slumber berries
she's out of her mind because they are
very strong it's so funny you said that
because
i was watching uh naked and afraid
uh which is a survival it's not survival
it's on the discovery channel it's great
but it's so dumb they got them all
blurred out at the top of the box
they really aren't naked on the show
they really are yeah they're straight up
naked absolutely
it doesn't make any sense why because
you're in nature you can get stung by
stuff in the butt
well they well they do but and more they
do
and they do but but what's crazy is
they built because of all the snakes and
stuff
they built their bed high okay they
built their beds
or their or however they lay they built
it high
these guys built a fire underneath
okay gonna catch the bed on fire
wipe the bed on fire
oh yeah they're special kind of stupid
and he was all mad he was like
well because the whole bed caught on
because the bed got on fire
he woke up when that fire hit his ass
and he's like
and the cameraman is standing there
watching the whole time well at night i
think that yeah
yeah they can't they only have their own
cameras at night the cameramen leave at
night and come back during the day
unless they need a medic then they can
call for a medic i think which is on
standby
so anyways back to cbd gotta get it
20 off i know you guys are already
taking it a lot of you are taking cbd
already
go to cblion.compre get 20
off get the best cbd made here in
america yeah
you can't beat that you can and before
we go
uh you also don't forget to go to
mypiller.com
yeah you can click on radio specials
and check out everything there is
cheaper
under radio specials it's cheaper
but you can also use the code name wayne
for cheap well not cheap prices uh well
uh
discount prices all over the whole
website
and it's fun to just go on and like shop
and just take a look so after the show
just
just go to mypillow.com and yeah and
browse a little bit
and take a look at what they have uh at
least give yourself a couple minutes to
do that
you might find something you really need
or what okay edward wayne
before we go you can download this
episode of the wayne the pre podcast on
apple
spotify pandora i heart radio amazon
music
or any other platform that you
listen to your podcast now if you don't
have any
if you don't subscribe to any of those
and yep some of you are subscribing to
all of them and wasting all your money
it's just that right that's right i just
got the apple podcast yeah
just download the wayne dupree podcast
oh yeah the app
you can just download the app and listen
to us all day long
you'll be able to hear things like this
you're ready breaking news cdc to
reverse indoor mask policy saying fully
vaccinated and unvaccinated people
should wear masks
indoors no matter what and the cdc is to
also recommend
everyone k through 12 schools to wear
masks even if vaccinated
so they want to go fully back to the
masks everywhere indoors no matter what
rest assured there are lawsuits out
against that folks
so continue pushing back push back
but i knew i knew i knew and well
actually we knew
if you've been watching us we say it
it's a power thing when they realize
believe me they go in the back rooms and
they start talking about
you think we can get away with that too
yeah do you think we can add this
and they do and nobody does anything
nobody says anything
and the and the one network
i got a call from somebody last week
that told me to take down the story
yeah you did i i got a call from
somebody last week in the big time media
that told me to take down
if you said the name everybody would
know it air air
yeah rhymes with this no told me
everybody would know hey look he
dude uh person it run follow me shim
i told my ear nose and throat
doctor yesterday and he was like no he
did not call wayne i said yes he did
he called him personally he did she told
him
as a matter of fact it was john lennon
one of the people that worked with him
contacted me
first and i was like okay look just give
me a few seconds
let me go find out what the problem is
and then i get back with you next thing
i know
the person calls me singing hey pick up
i'm like damn okay well we gonna be on
the radio show right now okay
hello wayne yeah what you doing
i'm cooking next thing you know he's
like yeah
y'all y'all wrote a bad story about me
you better take that stuff down no i did
not well you know whatever on your
website
well you did the right thing you you
took it down yeah
so whatever that's all good yeah
whatever
all right with that said yeah ladies and
gentlemen
i have friends i i mean i have big time
friends i j
honestly before before i go i just don't
call on them
like everybody i don't lean on these
people you know why
because i'm not all about that you know
i would
rather open up the phones 24 7
and hear y'all honestly i would because
a lot of y'all have
great solutions now some of y'all are
nutty
but many of y'all have territory yeah
many of you have great solutions and
some of y'all
um have been holding your solutions for
years
and i'd rather hear that than to hear
somebody who goes from radio i
um to go from show to show to show to
show saying the same thing
all the time you can't learn anything
that way you can't
so there you go all right
we gotta go ten minutes over but i
promise oh shoot i gotta go get my hair
[Music]
okay